- Would you let your mom pick out
who you're going on a date with?
- Are you out of your mind?
If it was a two-way blind date,
they will shriek in horror
and they won't even sit down at the table.
- You think?
- Yeah.
- You never know what they're into.
There's a lot of
necrophiliacs running around.
- That's true.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Trixie Mattel.
- And I'm Katya.
- And we are two Queens who like to watch.
- Yes, we do, right here
on Netflix and guess what,
we're also gay.
(both gasps)
- You're gay?
- I'm glad we're gay
because today we are watching,
"Single All the Way,"
an LGBTQIA+ romp about being
single around the holidays.
(Katya coughs)
- Can't relate, except I can.
I've been single all the
way, all my life, and gay.
- Not just Christmas?
- No, no.
- Guy Fawkes Day, Arbor Day.
- Memorial Day, Labor Day.
- Leif Erikson Day.
- All. Easter Weekends, yeah.
- Talk Like A Pirate Day.
- Yeah.
- Opening Day, Good Friday.
(techno music)
- As usual, we might talk
about intricate plot points.
So, spoilers ahead.
- I would also love to address
the elephant in the room.
She's back!
- Hey, thank you, wow, I've returned.
And thank you to Jujubee and Jinx and Fena
for filling in.
I know that my shoes are
particularly difficult
to fill partially because
no one likes them.
So thank you.
(Katya laughs)
Can you believe no one likes this?
(upbeat music)
Not even washed, look at the texture,
and if you wanna know-
- It's pretty.
- What would you call that cut?
Cool Ranch Dorito?
(Katya laughs)
What is that?
Let's watch, "Single All The Way."
(techno music)
So Peter is directing a
photo shoot for Insta gays
and he's barely paying attention.
- [Katya] Oh my God, no, really?
- [Trixie] I know, and we're
gonna meet his roommate, Nick.
- He's been in a relationship for 22 days,
but who's counting, and
he's going to the party
with someone else.
- Oh, are they gonna be
friends who fall in love?
(upbeat music)
- I know him.
- You do?
- [Katya] That's Kyle Krieger, yes.
- He is pumped honey.
- I know him.
- Pumped.
- That's yeah, that's Kyle.
- Pumped honey, pumped.
- Shoot went great.
Yeah, got everything that we talked about.
- [Trixie] You think
Michael Urie's Jewish?
There's something I like about him,
I think it's his Jewishness.
- He must be Jewish if you like him.
- Yes, all the abs.
Hey, Lachlan, listen...
- That's a lot of (beep) plants.
That's a lot of (beep) that's
a lot of (beep) plants.
- I think it's character development.
He's probably like, you're
afraid of commitment with people.
"You just love your plants."
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
"You don't want (beep) me.
"You want to go home and rub
that aloe on your (beep)."
- You look a little sad today, Linda.
(water spraying)
I think I know what this is about.
- [Katya] Oh.
- You talking to your cigarette butts,
that you keep an ashtray
that you mist every morning.
- I was going to say,
if I'm misting something
it's not alive (laughs).
- When Zack broke my heart,
changed my life forever.
If it weren't for you,
I wouldn't have any of my other plants.
Ow, ow (scoffs) Judith!
Don't be jealous.
- Okay.
- I love you too.
(dog barks)
- You know-
- Oh, hey, boys.
You need to get ready for the party.
- [Katya] Is this his boyfriend?
- I don't have anything plaid.
- Yes, you do because
I knew you'd do this.
- You officially know me too well.
- I'm ordering the Uber.
- Wow.
- [Katya] Oh, if anybody
orders me an Uber,
I cut them out of my life.
- Why?
- I do. I travel on my own terms.
- I get that.
- In my own terms.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I get that.
- I'll say when I'm ready.
- Oh, guys (smooching).
This is wow.
- [Trixie] I like him, I
like the real (beep) one.
- Yeah, have you been to fancy parties?
I never get invited to parties.
- I think people throw them,
but they don't invite us.
- Do you want one with you in it?
- No, it's for my plant account.
- Oh.
- I keep my plant Instagram
and my personal Instagram separate.
- Well, I love how much you love plants.
- I love how much you love hearts.
- It's kinda my job to love hearts.
- All right.
- Well, hopefully someday
it'll be my job love plants.
- It's almost like you want us.
Do you want to hurt me?
- They can't understand why I haven't been
in a relationship that hasn't
lasted more than a few months.
- [Katya] Good, shut him up.
- Problem solved (chuckles).
- Come home with me.
- [Trixie] Leave the heart
patients at the hospital.
Let them go.
(phone vibrates)
- I'm sorry.
- [Katya] Work is calling.
- Crap, the hospital needs me.
I'm so sorry.
- No, it's okay, it's a sign.
- [Katya] Beep beep, my job is
calling in a Hollywood movie
it's just too much.
- This might be the table flipping.
- It's going to get flipped because I-
- I think there'll be a moment
where we look at each other.
- This piece of (beep)
IKEA table is flying through the air.
(bright upbeat music)
- Look at all these nice cookies (gasps).
The cookies say 'gaslight,'
'gatekeep' and 'girlboss.'
- Okay.
- Oh, this is marshmallow.
- Was that real or soap?
- It's real.
Let's see what's going on.
(Katya claps)
Who's single?
(bright upbeat music)
- So we learn that Peter was
in a relationship with a man
who had been married to a woman (gasps).
And that's why he's trying to
bring his new boyfriend home
with him because he's heartbroken still
and he's in love with plants.
- I'm not gonna judge
whatever journey you're on.
It's just not what I'm looking for
and I hope that you never do
it to anybody else ever again.
- [Trixie] Nice.
- I didn't wanna tell you,
"but I'm his wife."
- You had to.
(Katya laughs)
"I am a girl."
And then he's a girl.
- Well, the all-you-can-eat
buffet in Los Angeles
has served me nothing
but seven heartbreaks,
a mountain of therapy
debt and a chipped tooth.
- [Katya] No herpes? No gonorrhea?
- Maybe it's not LA.
Maybe you choose the wrong guys.
- [Trixie] Hello! We
have a nugget of truth.
Don't even get me started.
Gay guys love to be like,
"I'm moving to Ohio,
'cause the guys here suck."
Maybe it's you Kellen.
- Yeah, maybe (laughs).
- Maybe it's you, Brad.
- Yeah.
- "I'm going to another town
'cause everything," Guess what?
When you go to that town,
you're also going to be there.
So it's going to suck.
- Yeah, wherever you go,
there you are.
- I'll be guncle, and
a plant lady forever.
And plants don't cheat.
- [Katya] Plants don't (beep) either.
- Is he dicking down these plants?
Is he dicking down a fern?
- Is he wrapping those vines
around his little wing nut?
- [Trixie] Oh, too many
plants, too many plants.
- I don't want you to
be here all by yourself,
reminiscing about all
the great Christmases
you had with your mom as a kid.
- [Trixie] Your mom died I guess.
- Oh.
- Dead moms in movies?
Oh God. Guess whose mom dies?
Everyone's. Get a new storyline.
- The first book you
wrote became a bestseller
and now you have all
this money in the bank
that you're saving for a rainy day.
- By the way, he doesn't,
because books don't pay that much.
- Books don't pay that much.
Although a kid's book.
How long does it take
to read a kid's book?
- Two hours.
- An afternoon?
(Katya laughs)
We could write some like pandering,
like (beep) little like
"Sometimes Men Wear Wigs" a la
like "Everyone Poops."
And we could do like an Oprah book tour.
- "Your Dad's A Crossdresser."
- "Why does daddy have a corset-"
- Yeah, "Where does Daddy go?"
"What's the Tiffany Club?"
(bright upbeat music)
- We're meeting Peter's family.
And his mother is trying to
set him up on a blind date
because in this reality, a gay
person's parents care whether
or not they have a boyfriend.
- Yeah.
- Kathy Najimy.
Kathy Najimy.
- [Katya] Oh, she looks fabulous.
(both laughing)
- I'm so happy right now.
- Is she in pain?
- Her IUD.
- "I got shot but I don't
care, 'cause it's Christmas."
- "I'm so happy right now.
- Is that blood?"
- You told Lisa that you
were bringing home a surprise
and we thought maybe-
- [Trixie] A spell book?
- [Katya] She's reading the Bible?
Oh, she's doing "Hocus Pocus."
"Book!"
- And my early Christmas
present for you is
a blind date.
- PFLAG mom. PFLAG mom.
What did I tell you?
"I'm not at the parade,
but what the (beep) are you
doing it at the parade, Val?"
- Now, if I caught my mom in a gay parade,
- You would gay bash her.
- Entirely, I'd be like
"Go home (beep) baby!"
I don't know what I would say.
(Katya laughs)
"(beep) enabler!"
"Anal intercourse!"
- Nicolas, always good to see you.
- Oh me too.
- [Trixie] Wait a minute
that's Barry Bostwick
from "Rocky Horror."
That's Brad.
- Are you serious?
- I'm dead serious.
- Holy (beep).
- I might not be serious.
- Can we look it up?
- If I'm right,
I'm flipping the table.
- How do you know?
That would be remarkable.
Sometimes you don't recognize me.
(both laughs)
I did think you were a table
lamp for about six weeks.
- [Director] His name is Barry Bostwick.
- B*tch, everybody can eat my ass.
- I love a little competition with no one.
And also I'm a little bit offended.
How come you didn't ask
me to fix your pipe?
- [Katya] "Cause you don't
know how to do (beep)."
- Come on let's go.
- And you're very talented,
you're good at so many things.
- Oh, like, fixing my poisettias.
- That's spell book, she just
opens up like a jar of cicadas
and dumps them in. A baby's arm...
Chicken foot.
Okay, Kathy Najimy is turning
the party in this movie.
She's she feels like a real mom.
She's delivers it, it's funny.
- Yeah, she's effervescent.
She's your friend's mom, you're
like, "I love that (beep)."
- Yeah.
- Remember when you were a kid
and you become like friends
with your friend's mom?
- I became friends with a lot of moms.
- I bet you did. And a lot of dads.
- Do you know, just quickly-
- I do.
- My most recurring
sexual fantasy involves
(beep) dad in my childhood neighborhood,
going door to door and
(beep) each one of them.
And the way that I do it.
- Like a Mormon?
- No, no, no, no.
Not the same day.
- Oh, okay.
Are you in drag?
- No.
- Okay, are they?
(Katya laughs)
- They're all dressed as Santa Claus
and I'm inside one of the presents.
- Hot, Santa Claus outfits are hot.
- Super hot.
Aunt Sandy arrives, but mistakes
Nick for Peter's boyfriend.
Who do you think it is?
- I think it's like a
CGI of Princess Leia.
Like they do in the
new "Star Wars" movies.
It's like a Carrie Fisher CGI.
This is where the real budget comes in.
♪ Joy to the world the Lord has come ♪
- Work (beep.)
- Jen Coolidge.
- Personal friends.
- Personal friend of the show.
Hi, Jen.
(Katya laughs)
I went out to dinner with her once
and this was not Christmas,
it was like September.
She made a headband with hot glue
that had two Christmas trees
and she put them on the
headband. September.
She wore it to a nice
restaurant, like that.
- 'Joy to the World'
means to be in your show.
- Well, yes.
- It's got the king, the
savior, the glory and the born.
What a handsome new boyfriend.
- "No, we're not together,
he can never get me."
- But he might have a boyfriend tomorrow.
- [Katya] Oh my God,
she's really laying it on thick.
- What's tomorrow?
- Well, he's going on a date.
- Like, from Grindr?
- No.
- Work (beep)! That's
fierce, that's fierce.
- [Trixie] The way that
rolled off Jennifer's tongue.
- I know, I know.
- Thank you so much.
- I think they be together.
- Yes, same.
- [Katya] Oh, they're gonna get together?
- [Trixie] They are going to get together.
- These gorgeous stars came
with the trees, I love them.
- I do too.
- Oh, work!
- Give.
- Oh.
(bright upbeat music)
- So Peter heads out on
his blind date with James
and they hit it off.
- Oh my God.
Honey, gay people getting along.
What's next? Flying cars?
(upbeat music)
Oh my God.
(techno music)
- So, this is James who I told you about
and this is my son, Peter...
We're supposed to believe this
person came from Los Angeles
and has never seen biceps?
He's going to get out of
there and go (beep) a townie.
- You probably thought
you were going on a date
with the hottest, smartest,
funniest, coolest,
most interesting person who was ever born.
- Maybe I am.
(Michael gurgles)
- Oh, oh, I'm so so sorry.
- I'm sorry.
- Is this a good date?
Is someone going to whip a nut out
or something like?
- Here I am.
(Peter gurgles)
- No, let me get you a towel.
- Oh, thank you.
(both laughs)
- [Trixie] Mrs. Claus's.
- Are you okay?
- Yeah, I got it.
- They stumbled and the
tree goes right up his ass.
- Yeah.
- "Oh no (beep)."
That does happen, people think like,
if you're gay and you have a gay friend,
your family is like, "I thought
that was your boyfriend."
I was like, "No, we just
take dance lessons together."
- Yeah, well, all gay
people know each other.
You know what?
That is the stereotype but it is true.
- "I have a gay friend. His name is John.
Do you know him?"
"Of course, I've sucked
him off three times."
- That's what I mean.
"Do you know my cousin,
Daniel from Ohio? He's gay."
I'm like, "Oh yeah, I never
met him, but I have pictures
of his (beep) on my phone."
- Yeah.
All right, bring on Sandy.
She's rehearsing for the play.
- I need to see you scared.
- So, why don't you just show me?
(Sandy screaming loudly)
- Work.
Try that.
- Unless you look deeper,
there's nothing particularly
remarkable about Mary.
- What a weirdo.
That's my favorite part.
(techno music)
- Peter gets home from
his second date with James
and tells Nick all about it.
- It's so obvious.
How come only Grandpa sees what we see?
All you have to do is look at
their faces, it's pure love.
- If I know anything
about teenagers it's that
they have all the time
in the world to set up-
- Elderly gay people.
- Elderly homosexuals.
- Yeah.
- Why are you looking out of the window?
- "Why are you looking out of the window?"
- What's happening?
- No, no, no.
- "Are you and your friends
going down to Provincetown
to have a glory hole?"
(Katya laughs)
"That's fun."
- "Poppers, G, K."
(Katya laughs)
"Sure."
(techno music)
All right, so Peter asked
Nick to help him by modeling
for a photo shoot and
things turn very charming.
- You look at me though.
(camera shutters)
Okay one more.
- [Katya] Have you ever done that?
- Chop wood?
- No. Took a picture? (laughs)
- Turn, one two, three, go.
Oh, oh, smolder.
- [Katya] "All right, let's try one,
maybe without your shirt."
- [Trixie] "And what if
you know in this one,
you're holding a wine glass
and you have a half chub?"
"And, no, still hold the ax."
- Oh yeah.
- Oh my God.
- I'm sorry.
- Have I been using shaving
cream wrong this whole time?
Are you supposed to wear it?
- That's really cute.
- I have an idea what I want to do.
- Like what?
- "Take off your pants."
- Three, breathe out so I can
see the fog on your breath.
- [Katya] What the (beep) is that?
- [Trixie] They're doing art.
- [Katya] This is (beep) Oh,
is this is what people do?
- I mean you're in your
house with a fake (beep) on,
with a baby filter on.
And you're like, "That's weird."
- That is a really good point.
- You should come with.
- No.
- Don't bring the friend on the date.
- I hope he keeps the shaving cream on
the whole time though, that'd be fun.
(techno music)
- So Peter's trying to do the
shaving cream picture again,
but there's no chemistry
this time without Nick.
- This is random, but you
wouldn't be interested
in being in a razor ad for
Instagram, if they pick you.
Would you?
- Oh, this poor, these...
- Oh geez.
- Jesus.
- Oh, this is me.
- Oh.
- Do you want to come up?
- Sure.
Actually, I should probably
go home, the girls need me.
- These guys are forty.
What is this girlish,
coquettish like skittishness?
- "Would you possibly be-"
- They're all Kristen
Stewart 20 years ago.
"I dunno."
- "You nicknamed my daughter
after the Loch Ness Monster!?"
- I'll see you tomorrow.
- Okay.
- Goodnight.
- Can I just say this.
- Please.
- He is too advanced of
a gay age to do this like
"First date, like, oh, am I hot enough?"
Like you are 45 (beep) years old.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You have done anal.
- Yeah.
- The real-
- You have no reason to do this coy,
like, "Is he going to be impressed?
Guess I'll be alone with my plants."
"What am I going to (blubbering)."
- You don't need to be like, (blubbering)
Oh and guess (beep) what?
I bet that they get together.
And he writes another book
and it's about their
(beep) Christmas together.
I guarantee you. I'll flip this couch.
That microphone? Straight up my ass.
(Katya laughs)
(techno music)
There's a performance going on.
And the whole family gets involved
and they're performing
a rousing Britney track.
The risk is too,
if Nick and I ever went
there and it didn't work out,
I would lose him.
I don't want that to happen.
- The way that I not be confiding
as a 45 year old gay man in a
16 year old girl from Idowa.
Idowa.
- I don't know who this person,
this person doesn't exist.
- This person doesn't exist.
This is the (beep) this
is the ghost of Christmas
Never Happened.
- Oh my God.
- Britney, our song.
I wasn't even thinking that I was just-
- I'm finding it, I'm
finding it, let's go.
- Do we all remember the choreography!?
- Oh, we've only missed
you ever since we watched.
♪ Oh yeah yeah yeah ♪
- Crazy.
♪ Last night I took a walk in the snow ♪
Jesus Christ.
♪ Seems like everyone but me is in love ♪
♪ Santa, can you hear me ♪
♪ I signed my letter that
I sealed with a kiss ♪
♪ I sent it off and just said this ♪
♪ I know exactly what I want this year ♪
♪ Santa, can you hear me? ♪
I'm gay, but I'm not that gay
(table flips)
- What are we watching?
What are we watching?
What is this representative of?
This isn't gay!
And it's not Christmas!
What the (beep) is this?
This ShopCo commercial,
I'm gonna lose my mind.
I'm going to lose my mind on this day.
What the (beep) is happening?
Who is this?
Who are these people?
♪ Underneath my Christmas tree ♪
♪ I'll be waiting here ♪
♪ Santa that's my only wish this year ♪
(screen beeping)
- Aunt Sandy's performing for the town.
- Oh, cool.
- Come on Aunt Sandy.
- There's stars in the sky.
- Why is she Glinda? Why is she Glinda-
Why is she Glinda for Christmas?
That's fun.
- Yeah it is fun.
- This is why the gays like you.
- And the Holy Spirit will come.
- Oh, pissed.
They're just BFFs, Jon Hamm. Don't worry.
- How could I have a son?
- The Holy Spirit will come
and his power will give a baby.
- Okay, that's not what happened.
(Katya laughs)
That's not what happened.
- They had sex.
- To save her aching legs,
- "She chopped them off."
- Mary rode a donkey.
- [Katya] Urban donkey?
- [Trixie] Gangnam Style donkey?
Oh, that's fun. A blanket.
♪ Joy to the world the Lord has come ♪
- Jesus H Christ.
The banner says Jesus H Christ.
- What does H stand for.
- I have no idea.
- Hunkydory.
What an absolute freak.
I love Jennifer.
She is so (beep) funny.
She's a (beep) nutcase.
You know what else?
And I say this as a person
who likes admittedly,
a lot of white (beep), I guess.
The whiteness. This
Clorox chugging family.
- The free time.
- The money.
- It's crazy.
So just like in Clueless,
Peter realizes "I love Nick."
- I'm ready to retire.
All it needs is a paying job
and it will be ready to go.
- "My dying wish was
for a couple of (beep)
to open a plant store in it."
- How do you to sell plants
when they grow outside for free?
(piano music)
- Hey, why didn't you
respond to any of my texts
or call me back?
- Take a moment.
Catch your breath.
- While you do that,
- I have something to give you.
- [Trixie] Finally sex.
[Katya] My prolapsed rectum.
- I'm in love with you too.
(soft piano music)
I always have been, I
just needed a little-
(Katya laughs)
- I think I need my appendix out again.
- Do you have two?
- I think I have six.
Your best friend's hot and rich.
- Yeah.
- He's a dingle.
(Katya laughs)
He's a Dingle All The Way.
All the way.
(Katya laughs)
- "You dingle. You poop,"
"You cockadoodie dingle poop."
- I mean, I can work from anywhere.
In fact, it wasn't until I got here
that I started writing the new book.
- Oh my God, you (beep) bitch?
- Yeah.
- What'd I tell you?
- You told me.
- I've been ready for a
family for a long time.
- I can't wait to tell them.
- If someone's that hot,
chemistry class comes way later
because you're (beep) and suckin'.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You're (beep) and suckin' all day long
and then you'll figure out,
"Oh, he's kind of dickhead."
(screen beeps)
- I love presents. "Christmas Carole."
♪ Seems to say ♪
A vest? No one wants that.
"No selfies in the bathroom"
"Bloom where you planted" You guys.
All the words on the wall.
- "Good."
- Another one that says-
Another one that says "Perfect."
That one says "Perfect."
This is (beep) crazy.
This is crazy.
- It's completely insane.
- This is "Get Out."
This is a recut of "Get Out."
- It is "Gay Out." "Gay Out."
- It's a holiday "Get Out."
I might start reading again.
- The new Emmett book?
- I want to know what you guys think
before I sent it to my publisher.
- "Here's some homework for
Christmas, you (beep) ghoul."
What the hell?
- Hey, this movie has everything.
- Gay people, straight people.
- A Christmas pageant.
- Many lovely plants.
- So many plants.
- Too many (beep) white people.
- Jennifer Coolidge.
- Kathy Najimy.
- Michael Urie.
- Barry Bostwick.
- Jennifer Coolidge again.
So check out "Single All
The Way" on Netflix.
Happy holidays.
- Happy holidays.
- Christmas time is here.
(soft upbeat music)